so all eyes are on italy as england
prepare for their euro 2020
quarter-finals against ukraine the
disappointment
of that semi-final against germany 25
years ago
has finally been banished for that then
young player who missed a penalty uh the
other person
in that image of course david seaman
he's with us now
um hello to david good morning
do you remember that oh i do
yeah not very fondly but i remember last
night a lot better now
i'm sure just talk to me about that
picture and then we'll talk about last
night
you went over to console him didn't you
um how was he
yeah you know you can understand how he
felt you know and it's just that we all
wanted to tell him that we'd all done a
great job
um you know but obviously gareth felt
that
you know because of what he'd done he'd
let people down and and that's the
feeling you you get when you make
mistakes you know i had that in
2002 you know but um yeah
i'm so happy for gareth because you know
that that must have felt
so so good last night for him he looked
absolutely thrilled didn't he sort of
looked up to the sky
um there he is applauding the england
team and we see images of him as well
looking up to the sky
and thanking i don't i'm not sure which
god he supports if any of
at all but he was certainly very pleased
with the
result he's broken that demon now hasn't
he
he certainly has you know we talked
about before you know about gareth karma
and retribution and all this sort of
stuff you know because he's been
a long time that he's got to deal with
that you know and now he's got this as a
manager
to have beaten the germans and it was it
was a great day you know and it was
great being at the ground as well and
just feeling the atmosphere feeling the
passion from the fans and the noise the
noise was incredible
1966 was the last time we beat the
germans uh in a knockout competition
that really does illustrate uh how
important last night was for england
he does you know and with all the all
the pressure that was built up before
you know people
questioning his team selection and
formation
and you know now i think we've all got
to sit back applaud gareth
and just say yeah you got it right when
it mattered and he certainly did you
know and
when i heard that they were going to a
back three i was like oh gosh i don't
know whether i'm i'm happy with this and
when when i was watching the game it was
the perfect firm
formation to pick and uh these are great
images by the way of uh
bobby moore with the world cup and stuff
and it's just uh
it's amazing to see and on last night
was so
so cool it sure was do you think we
might be seeing kane with the
european cup well that would be
ace you know the good thing about
yesterday as well was that harry got off
the mark you know and it was
it was a tough finish that he had you
know it was a ball that was played a
little bit behind him and he had to get
the header on it and um
it was just great it was a great team
performance um you know not you know
even
even with raheem sterling scoring again
you know
and showing what he can do you know
everybody knows how good he is i know
how good he can be
but he's doing it on the massive stage
now and it's uh
it was great it was just great you know
everybody coming on even with jack
greeley's coming on and
making that impact um it was just a
fantastic day and a fantastic place to
be
as an england fan and i really enjoyed
myself
could you choose between it being more
satisfying seeing kane's score
or the relief for southgate
um um excuse me i'm i'm more happy for
gareth if i'm honest because
you know i was there when it all
happened a long long time ago
um and i know that hurt that he was
feeling but um
yeah it's been a long time coming and
i'm so happy for garrett
um there we go the england fans are
certainly very happy
as well um talk to me about the big
gloves that
that had to be filled when you no longer
played for england how's our present
goalie doing
he's doing really well you know he's
made some big saves in the um
in the group stages um and he made a
couple of
important saves yesterday there was one
that was above him you know which was a
fast reaction save
and then he had a one or 1v1 um where he
blocked it and then he had a 1v1 where
he got pretty wide
um and that was important that jordan
you know he stayed big and he made
he made the guy mr missed the target and
i'm very happy for him obviously he
looks very very pleased and he's got
he's got every right to feel like that
because that was an amazing night and
like i've said before okay you know it's
time for these guys to create their
their own history
and um and that's exactly what they're
doing you know they're beating the
germans now
it's ukraine next but please everyone
don't underestimate
ukraine because they're a good team you
know we still need to be at our best to
beat them
uh yeah we certainly do and it's in rome
on saturday
fans can't go because they can't isolate
for long enough
in time to be able to watch the game on
saturday night
what impact will it have not having
england fans in the stadium
um yeah it will be because of the
atmosphere that
that i saw and felt yesterday that that
was amazing you know
and it was only half full um but it was
still
a lot of noise um england will miss that
but i'm sure that they'll be thinking
right let's do this for the fight and
let's get through this round and then
get
get everyone back to wembley and uh
hopefully
be next playing the semi-final at
wembley yeah i'm just a bit worried
about them travelling
and concerns about covid
yeah i know but they've got to obey by
the rules
um you know everybody has we know that
um
but you know i'm sure that the
authorities will uh will make sure that
that happens
and um yeah you've got to respect all
the all of the coded restrictions
yeah exactly but we did see two of the
players having to self-isolate didn't we
caused quite a few challenges and uh
southgate mentioned it
at the time of course whenever you
travel out the country and then you come
back again that increases any risk of
of getting covered they'll do everything
they can to try and keep them safe we
need all of them now don't we to go
through to the semis
yeah we do we need everybody fighting
fit and um you know the two guys are
back now and um
yeah it's it's a massive game for us um
but you know is it is it one that where
we feel like we did against germany now
we feel that we can win it but we've
still got to show the respect of the of
ukraine because
it will be a tough game yeah worried
about belgium
yeah belgium they're ticking along
nicely and they're getting better and
better but
if i'm honest so are we you know we are
getting better and better you know
even that performance yesterday as good
as it was i still feel we've got more to
give
you know we we respected germany because
we knew that they could be a threat
um but i still feel that we've got a lot
more to give and a lot more attacking
player
football coming home i hope it does
change because
i want to be around when he does i want
to get involved in that party
yeah you and me both it's good to talk
to you david we'll speak to you soon
thanks a lot love to frankie thank you
all right take care bye bye bye bye
thank you
oh it's great isn't it we're all so
excited and the reason is of course
because you know if you've been living
on the moon it's 55 years 1966 since we
last
beat germany in a knockout competition
playing
ukraine on saturday night uh
in rome fans can't be there as david was
saying
but if they get through that round then
we move back
to uh wembley for the semi-finals and
the final if
we get that far perhaps belgium in the
final
beating them three-nil let me know what
you think